another big story this morning uber may
be headed for a leadership shake-up the
ride hailing giant is reportedly
considering a leave of absence for CEO
Travis kalanick following a turbulent
six months company has faced
discrimination bullying and sexual
harassment allegations and investigation
into Ebers troubled culture by former
attorney General Eric Holder he's
expected to be released tomorrow we
reached out to Eber for comment but have
yet to hear back CBS News financial
contributor Mellody Hobson is in San
Francisco
good morning melody good morning so we
know that Ober held this emergency board
meeting on Sunday to discuss this report
by the former attorney General Eric
Holder this is more than just the top of
Eber there'll be a big shake-up
allegedly right well what we know right
now is that the biggest news to come out
of this meeting was that the board
unanimously agreed to take the
recommendations that are made in the
Indy report and I'm told by my source
that the recommendations are specific I
could not get the specifics but I do
know they fall in three categories
Human Resources governance and culture
so those are the big issues that they're
looking at the shake-up is still unclear
do we know these things that that he
Travis did the culture that he created
is it responsible for the huge success
of the company this is part of the issue
and this is a significance of the idea
that he may take a league of of absence
what I am told is his idea this brash
culture is what has led this company to
go from zero to being worth almost 70
billion dollars in seven years that is
explosive growth by any standards and
certainly has had some significant
fallout how big of a deal would that be
melody if Travis does in fact take a
leave of absence and how often does that
happen it would be a big deal first and
foremost let's talk about the timing the
timing would absolutely be
understandable because on Friday he
buried his mother after his parents had
a horrific boating accident so that may
be reason that he wants to take the
break potentially additionally however
right now the company has a host of open
jobs
they're looking for a CFO a chief
marketing officer a chief operations
officer a general counsel and a senior
vice president of engineers all at once
so the idea that the CEO might step away
at that time could be really really
problematic not to mention there's a
discussion that has close confidant and
number two might also step away but to
me like oh you're talking about yeah
corral melded is also breaking news
about GE the CEO Jeff ml retiring
are you surprised and how do we assess
his tenure well his departure has not
been telegraphed but he's been there a
long time
17 years normally an S&P 500 CEO stays
six years so in some ways it's not
surprising alright Mellody Hobson thank
you very much for joining us this
morning always good to see you